although he is 94 years old mickey mouse
is without a doubt the most iconic of
walt disney's animated characters and
arguably the most popular cartoon
character in the world
[Music]
hello
hello
in today's lesson we'll take a look at a
clip from an episode of a time when
mickey and his friends tried to surprise
me by painting her new home but before
we do that each week we create fun
lessons like this to help english
learners like you understand fast
speaking natives without getting lost
without missing the jokes and without
needing subtitles so if you haven't
already done so join our global
community of over 6 million learners by
hitting that subscribe button and bell
down below so you never miss out on any
of our new lessons
fellas i gathered you here today because
this is minnie's new house and i really
want to surprise her by painting it
before she gets back it's got coconut
paint big flowery hat cutesy rootsy bow
that's good noel but i like to see where
inspiration takes me
oh no no i've got it all worked out all
we need is polka dot paint an
old-fashioned paintbrush and we'll be
done in no time agree to disagree
[Music]
fellas i gather you here today because
this is minnie's new house and i really
want to surprise her by painting it
before she gets back so mickey uses
connected speech here when the words
want and two are next to one another the
t at the end of want and at the
beginning of two both become silent
then the o in two takes on a schwa sound
so together these two words become
wanna
wanna
the words then flow into each other to
sound like i really wanna surprise her i
really want to surprise her listen again
and i really want to surprise her by
painting it before she gets back it's
got coconut paint big flowery hat cutesy
boat when something is flowery it is
covered with mini or has big flowers
however flowery has another meaning if a
speech or writing style is flowery it
uses too many complicated or unusual
words or phrases
whoa violet if i know a thing or two
about legends it's that all this flowery
underworld language is just a cover for
a con come on
we usually refer to a flower pattern as
a floral pattern
for example she is wearing a floral
dress
this is an informal almost childish
expression used when we want to say that
something is extremely or excessively
cute for example the baby looked cutesy
wootsy in her new dress
that's good noel but i like to see where
inspiration takes me we say that we will
see where something takes us when we are
not sure what the end result will be or
what will happen in the future so goofy
is saying that he enjoys painting
whatever he is inspired to do without
actually planning the end result for
example you could say
i'll see where the road takes me
which means i'll drive without planning
the destination
or we'll see where the relationship
takes us
which means we're not sure yet about the
future of our relationship another way
you could say this would be to see where
a situation goes
check out this example from friends
you're not expecting a proposal right
oh no no not at all
we're just moving in right now we'll see
where it goes
are you feeling inspired to improve your
english but you're not sure where to
start well without learning with friends
course you will have fun while greatly
improving your understanding of false
speaking natives learn the vocabulary
you actually need to communicate and
master grammar in context you can try
our course right now for free without
three-part masterclass simply sign up
now by clicking up here or down in the
description below
agree to disagree
so if two people who are arguing about
something agree to disagree they decide
to stop arguing because neither of them
is going to change their opinions
overhearing teenagers at the pier might
not be the best way to get information i
would agree to disagree because that's
actually how i learned that green
scrunchies are out
[Music]
this is school
hey nick i'm all done i just let
inspiration take me someplace mystical
what the plan was polka dots remember
polka dots why are you painting
don't use a brush come on you're wasting
time
[Music]
what is wrong with you people
[Music]
this is an idiomatic expression which
means that a situation is easy and
without any problems imagine a ship
sailing through rough waters it would be
dangerous and difficult to reach your
destination right however when the
waters are calm it's much easier to get
where you need to be that's why when a
situation is good and without any
trouble we say that it is smooth sailing
now go be free
should be smooth sailing from here
here's a quick tip about writing so when
a writer repeats the consonant sounds at
the beginning of a word in this case
smooth and sailing both start with the
consonant s
this is called alliteration although
there are several reasons to use it the
main reason to use alliteration in
writing is that it sounds pleasing
it gets the attention of the readers or
listeners let us know down in the
comments if you would like to learn more
about how to improve your writing in
english
i just let inspiration take me someplace
mystical
what
things that are mystical are magical or
mysterious usually having to do with the
supernatural or spiritual so when
something or some place is mystical it
cannot easily be understood or explained
together we would pull off the greatest
illusion of all shut it blackheart
i would bewilder you mere mortals with
my mystical powers
shut it black arts
just use a brush come on you're wasting
time did you notice the connected speech
here instead of saying come on the oh
income becomes a sure as the e at the
end of come is silent when the two words
link together it sounds like come on
come on
come on you're wasting time
so which of these do you think means the
same as what gives
what is happening
what is going on
or what is wrong
[Music]
all of them are correct
what gives is an informal expression and
is something you ask when you aren't
sure why someone is doing something or
acting in a certain way so for example
if someone has been behaving strangely
you could say
you've been acting weird all week what
gives
here's another example from the movie
turbo all right give me the keys i'll
drive the first shift home
it's common for us to shorten words when
we speak casually with friends and
family so here instead of saying hold on
a second he reduces second to sec
we usually use this expression to ask
someone to wait for a short moment
some other examples of words that are
commonly shortened include laboratory
becomes lab
limousine becomes limo
to the maximum becomes to the max
and legitimate becomes legit
i'm sorry i'm sorry i i did not mean to
scare you i no no wait
so when goofy asks am i right he isn't
actually expecting an answer this is
because he's asking a rhetorical
question which means this is a question
asked in order to make a statement that
does not expect an answer in other words
he actually believes he did a good job
painting
marceline
where is she oh boy i i wish i knew it
no love lost there am i right
now let's test what you've learned today
fellas i gathered you here today because
this is minnie's new house and i really
want to surprise her by painting it
before she gets back it's got coconut
paint big flowery hat cutesy bow that's
good noel but i like to see where
inspiration takes me
oh no
i've got it all worked out all we need
is polka dot paint an old-fashioned
paintbrush and we'll be done in no time
agree to disagree
which of these means the same as agree
to disagree
agree to differ agree to argue i beg
your pardon
[Music]
this is smooth
which of these options uses alliteration
eat your egg
fly in the pie
baby boy bruce
[Music]
hey nick i'm all done i just let
inspiration take me someplace mystic
what the plan was polka dots remember
polka dots why are you painting
don't use a brush come on you're wasting
time
hold on
what does mickey mean when he says this
get angry
calm down be excited
[Music]
what is wrong with you people
if you enjoyed today's lesson why not
watch this one next
hey real lifers so
many of my students ask me where's the
best place to start learning new
vocabulary
my answer probably
right at home
so today i'm going to teach you some
important vocabulary around the home as
well as some interesting idiomatic
expressions related to objects in the
home for example do you know the
difference between a photograph and a
portrait